สวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะครูบีสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนค่ะค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคน
นะคะค่ะขอต้อนรับนักเรียนทุกคนนะคะเข้า
สู่ห้องเรียนภาษาไทยห้องเรียน
comprehensible ไยค่ะ
อืมต้องชี้นะคะเออห้องเรียนของเราอยู่ที่
ไหนนะคะวันนี้ก็มาเจอกับครูบีแล้วก็ครู
ปุ๊กอีกแล้วนะเรามาเจอกันในวันอะไรคะวัน
เนี้ยวันนี้เป็นวันศุกร์แล้วค่ะวันศุกร์
อ่าวันที่เท่าไหร่แล้วคะครูปุ๊ก 23 ค่ะอ
เดือนอะไรคะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์ค่ะปีพ.ศอะไร
คะพุธศักราช
2567 ค่ะปีค.ศเหรอคะคริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะนะวันนี้เป็นวันศุกร์ที่ 23
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพุทธศักราช
2567 ปีคริสตศักราช 2024 ค่ะอืนะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์เนี่ยก็ใกล้จะหมดแล้วนะเพราะ
ว่าวันนี้เ่ะวันที่ 23 แล้วนะคะถูกต้อง
ค่ะแต่เดือนนี้เนี่ยปกติมี 28 วันแต่ปี
นี้เนี่ยมี 29 วันเลยนะครูบีเพิ่มมาอีก 1
วันนะคะใช่พอวันที่ 29 กุมภาพันธ์เนี่ยก็
หมดแล้วนะเดือนกุมภาพันธ์ก็หมดนะคะก็จะ
เริ่มเดือนที่ 3 เดือนมีนาคมเนาะใช่ค่ะ
กุมภาพันธ์ก็จะบ๊ายบายเพราะว่าเดือนนี้
เป็นเดือนแห่งความรักใช่
มยแต่เดือนแห่งความรักทำไมอากาศมันร้อนๆ
อยากจะไปเที่ยวภูเขาไปเที่ยวน้ำตกไม่ไป
ทะเลคิดว่าน่าจะร้อนมากไปภูเขาดีกว่ามี
ต้นไม้เยอะค่ะครูปุ๊กโอโหถ้าครูบีเเนี่ย
ไปภูเขาไปที่มีต้นไม้เยอะๆเนี่ยนะครูปุ๊ก
ก็คิดว่าบางทีเนี่ยครูบีก็ต้องระวังด้วย
นะอืระวังอะไรคะไปเที่ยวภูเขาอย่างเช่น
ครูบีอยากไปนะครูปุ๊กใกล้ๆกรุงเทพฯเลยนะ
คะใกล้ๆกรุงเทพอ๋อเขาใหญใหญ่เงี้
เอๆๆอันนี้โอเคนะูปุ๊กก็ไปเคยไปนะเคยไป
กางเต็นท์นอนด้วยอนะเขาใหญ่
นะเพราะว่าเขาใหญ่เนี่ยมีทั้งเอ่อรีสอร์ท
โรงแรมถ้าไม่ชอบนอนโรงแรมไม่ชอบนอน
รีสอร์ทก็ไปกลางเต็นท์นอนอย่างที่ครูปุ๊ก
บอกนะคะค่ะใครที่ชอบความสะดวกสบายก็นอน
โรงแรมนอนรีสอร์ทนะใครที่ชอบเราบอกว่า
เที่ยวแบบลุยๆลุยๆก็คือไม่ต้องสบายมากนะ
นะก็นะไปกางเต็นท์ได้ค่ะนะเจะมีสถานที่
เตรียมไว้ให้สำหรับกลางเต็นท์นะแล้วก็
อุปกรณ์ทำอาหารเนี่ยพวกเตาแล้วก็มีถ่านมี
ไฟเนี่ยทำบาร์บีคิวอย่างเงี้ยก็ไปเช่าเอา
ที่นั่นได้เค้ามีให้เช่าให้ยืมนะอ้าแปล
ว่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยเคยไปกางเต็นท์นอนมาแล้ว
หรอคะที่เขาใหญ่เคยค่ะเค้ามีที่สถานที่
ที่เราสามารถไม่ใช่ว่าที่ไหนก็กางได้นะ
ไม่ใช่นักเรียนไปแล้วออตรงนี้เราอยากเข้า
ไปตรงนี้แล้วก็ไปกางเต็นท์เพราะว่าที่เขา
ใหญ่เนี่ยมันยังเป็นแบบป่าธรรมชาติอยู่
เนาะแล้วก็ยังมีพวกสัตว์ป่าต่างๆที่เขาจะ
เดินไปเดินมาไม่ว่าจะจะเป็นช้างป่าตัว
ใหญ่ๆอย่างเงี้ย
โอยเดี๋ยวๆๆๆๆครูปุ๊กสมมติอะไรคะนี่ครูบี
มีรูปเขาใหญ่เนี่ยเห็นปะอือคือกลางเต็นท์
อยู่ในป่าอย่างงี้เลยหรอคะมีต้นไม้อย่าง
งี้เลยหรอใช่ก็คือเขาจะมีเอ่อส่วนที่กาง
เต็นท์ได้ก็คือไม่ใช่ส่วนที่เอ่อสัตว์ป่า
อยู่อืนะไม่ใช่ส่วนที่สัตว์ป่าเนี่ยจะ
เดินผ่านนะเค้าก็จะมีสถานที่ที่เขาบอกว่า
ที่สถานที่กลางเต็นท์ได้อ๋ออย่างอย่างใน
รูปภาพนี้ก็คือไม่มีช้างเดินมาที่นี่นะคะ
กำลังนอนอยู่เแร้นโไม่แน่ค่ะเพราะว่าเค้า
เป็นเราจะเรียกเหมือนเหมือนเจ้าถิ่นก็ได้
เป็นเจ้าของพื้นที่เนาเขาก็เดินไปทั่วล่ะ
ค่ะนะแต่ว่าโอกาสเนี่ยจะเดินมาตรงแหล่ง
ที่นักท่องเที่ยวอยู่นจะน้อยมากคือเจ้า
หน้าที่เนาะเจ้าหน้าที่ก็คือคนที่ทำงาน
เนี่ยของอุทยานแห่งชาติหรือว่าป่าเขาใหญ่
เนี่ยเขาก็จะคอยดูถ้ารู้ว่ามีช้างเดินที่
ไหนเนี่ยแล้วรบกวนเราเขาก็จะไปคอยดูค่ะ
นี่ไงโถ้าไปนอนแบบเก็เปลี่ยนบรรยากาศใช่
มยอ่าเหมือนเราทำงานอยู่กรุงเทพฯนี่
เหนื่อยมากเราก็สามารถไปกลางเต็นท์นอน
อย่างนี้ได้แต่ทำไมครูปุ๊กถึงบอกว่าต้อง
ระวังอ่ะคะนอกจากจะกลัวช้างปาก
อืกลัวสัตว์ป่าใช่มั้ยนะเวลาเดินเนี่ย
ปกติเนาะเพราะว่าที่ประเทศไทยเนี่ยบางที่
ก็จะมีงูด้วยงูออถ้าอย่างสัตว์ปลาเนี่ยก็
คือเราจะรู้อยู่แล้วว่ากลางกลางเต็นท์ตรง
ไหนใช่มั้ยอ่าบางทีสัตว์ป่าเนี่ยอาจจะไม่
เดินมาบริเวณนี้เพราะว่ามีเจ้าหน้าที่คอย
ดูแลว่าบริเวณนี้นี้กลางเต็นท์ได้ตรงนี้
กลางเต็นท์ได้แต่งูเนี่ยครูปุ๊กมันห้าม
ไม่ได้นะคะบอกงูห้ามมาไม่ได้นะแต่ก็จะมี
จะมีส่วนที่กางเต็นท์เนี่ยก็อาจจะไม่ได้
มีงูไงแต่เวลาเราเดินไปอ่ะเราไปหาสถานที่
ต่างๆไปเดินเที่ยวอะไรอย่างเงี้ยเราก็ไม่
รู้ไงว่ามันก็ในป่าเนี่ยมันมีงูอยู่แล้ว
แล้วงูในประเทศไทยเนี่ยมันก็มีทั้งงูที่
มีพิษกับงูไม่มีพิษค่ะอืแล้วก็ในป่าเนี่ย
เราสมมุติเราไปกางเต็นท์ใช่มั้ยบางที
เมื่อกี้เนี่ยมีต้นไม้ด้วยนะเอองูอาจจะ
อยู่บนต้นไม้ก็ได้กูปุ๊กเออเห็นมั้ยล่ะ
ถ้าเป็นงูมีพิษเนี่ยอันตรายนะคะน่ากลัว
มากอืมเพราะว่าประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีชื่อเสียง
นะคะเออคือมันก็จะเป็นงูที่อยู่ในแถบ
เอเชียตะวันออกเฉียงใต้เหมือนกันเนอะอก็
ก็จะเป็นหลายๆประเทศก็มีเหมือนๆเรานี่
แหละแต่ว่าถ้านักเรียนมาเที่ยวประเทศไทย
น่ะไม่ว่าจะเดินไปที่ไหนในป่าเนาะเราก็จะ
มีต้นไม้มีใบไม้ที่มันร่วงหล่นลงมาเนี่ย
บางทีเนี่ยเราก็ไม่ได้สังเกตไงเราไม่ได้
ดูดีๆการเดินเนี่ยก็ต้องระวังฟังด้วยเิน
ไปอาจจะเหยียบงูก็ได้เพราะว่างูในประเทศ
ไทยที่เราได้ยินเนาะว่าเป็นงูที่มีพิษ
แล้วทุกคนก็จะกลัวเนี่ยอือฮึจริงๆมีหลายๆ
ชนิดอืใช่มามาพูดถึงงูที่ครูบีกลัวก่อนดี
กว่าเวลาไปป่าไปภูเขาอย่างงี้
นะบอกว่างูอันดับแรกเลยที่ทุกคนรู้สึกว่า
ไม่อยากเจอไม่อยากเห็นอืคืองูอะไรคะครูบี
งูเห่าไงครูปุ๊กอ่าเพราะว่างูเข่าเนี่ยจะ
เป็นงูที่พบบ่อยที่สุดนะที่ในบรรดางูพิษ
ทั้งหมดนะอนะงูมีพิษก็คือกัดแล้วบางที
เนี่ยพิษเข้าหัวใจเราเราก็ตายได้ค่ะนะอ
แล้วที่เราเรารู้จักมากๆแล้วก็เจอบ่อยๆ
เพราะว่างูเห่าเนี่ยค่ะกูปุ๊กเห็นมมบางที
เนี่ยอย่างที่บ้านครูบีที่อีสานเนี่ยมี
ฟาร์มข้าวปลูกข้าวเนี่ยก็จะมีงูเห่ามากๆ
นะคะออมันมาทำอะไรคะงูเห่าเนี่ยโอครูปุ๊ก
มันก็มาหากินสัตว์
ออสัตว์ตัวเนี้ยมันชอบมากค่ะอะไรคะสัตว์
อะไรที่งูเนี่ยชอบกินแล้วมันก็ชอบมาอ
เพราะว่าสัตว์ตัวเนี้ยก็ชอบนาข้าวมากๆ
เพราะว่าสัตว์ตัวนี้ก็คือหนูค่ะครูปุ๊ก
มันก็จะมากินข้าวใช่มยที่ทุ่งนาที่ฟาร์ม
ข้าวนะงูเนี่ยก็จะตามมาเพราะงูจะมากินหนู
ค่ะ
อ๋อเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยก็คือพอเราชาวนาเนี่ย
ปลูกข้าวอพอข้าวเนี่ยมีเม็ดแล้วมีเม็ด
ข้าวแล้วเนาะออกรวงเม็ดข้าวหนูเนี่ยมันก็
จะมาขโมยข้าวกินใช่มยใช่นะคะเพราะฉะนั้น
หนูจะเยอะตอนช่วงนั้นหนูนาแล้วก็งูเนี่ย
มันก็จะมากินหนูอือ้าถูกต้องค่ะส่วนครู
บีเเนี่ยก็จะกินงูกินหนูเอามา
บาร์บีคิวครูบีกินงูกินหนูกิน
ข้าวเออนะ
ครูบีน่ากลัวกว่าใช่มั้ยครูบีน่ากลัวกว่า
งูเห่า
ใช่นะแสดงว่างูเห่าเนี่มันเห่าเก่งหรอคะ
้าๆๆเหมือนหมาเหรอไม่มีเสียงครูปุ๊กแต่
เมื่อกี้ที่เปิดรูปให้ครูปุ๊กดูเนี่ยงู
เห่าเนี่ยสังเกตง่ายนะคะทำไมคะสังเกตยัง
ไงคที่หัวที่หัวค่ะ
อ่าเวลาปกติเนี่ยเเลื้อยมันก็จะหัวจะเล็ก
ๆเหมือนงูธรรมดาเนาะอืแต่เมื่อไหร่เค้าตก
ใจขึ้นมาเนี่ยเค้าจะชูคอขึ้นมาแล้วก็แผ่
แม่เบี้ยเห็นมั้ยหัวเขาเนี่ยเหมือนจะใหญ่
ขึ้นอันนี้เราเรียกว่าแผ่แม่เบี้ยมันมัน
จะแบบใหญ่ออกมาแบบนี้ใช่มั้ยแผ่ออกมาแล้ว
อย่างรูปเนี้ยเห็นมั้ยคะข้างหน้าเนี่ย
เออเราก็จะเห็นว่าอุ้ยมันแผ่แม่เบี้ยแต่
เราก็ยังไม่แน่ใจเอ๊ะมันงูเห่ามั้ยเออ
เพรามันมีงูบางชนิดก็แผ่แม่เบี้ยเหมือน
กันนะอืดีนะใช่แต่ว่าเราจะสังเกตยังไงว่า
เป็นงูเห่าอ่ะครูบีนี่เลยครูปุ๊กก็ดูนะคะ
เห็นมั้ยคะอือฮึข้างหลังค่ะนี่มี
โลโก้โลโก้ของอะไร
ค่ะการบินไทยรึเปล่าไแวเหรออเออก็คล้ายๆ
นะเหมือนนะเอออต้องเอียงดูอย่างงี้นะใช่
นะเห็นมั้ยที่หัวของงูนะด้านหลังเนี่ยบาง
บางครั้งเราดูข้างหน้าแล้วมันแผ่แม่
เบี้ยวออกมาเนี่ยเราก็ยังไม่แน่ใจใช่มั้ย
ว่าเป็นงูอะไรแต่พอเห็นด้านหลังเนี่ย
โอ้โหใชตัว 100% งูเห่าค่ะมีโลโก้อยู่เลย
นะคะอืใช่ค่ะค่ะแล้วก็มันก็ชอบออกหากิน
ตอนกลางคืนเนาะใช่มยอ่าตอนกลางวันมันก็
อาจมันร้อนค่ะนะมันก็อาจจะอยู่ในรูใช่มย
ในเพราะว่ามันก็ชอบเข้าไปกินหนูแล้วก็อาจ
จะอยู่ในบ้านของหนูหรือเปล่าอืเพราะว่า
บอกแล้วว่างูมีพิษในประเทศไทยเนี่ยมีหลาย
ชนิดเราก็เลยต้องดูให้แน่ใจว่ามันเป็นงู
อะไรไงกูปุ๊กใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าถ้ามีงูมีพิษ
เนี่ยกัดแล้วเนี่ยเราก็ตายค่ะนะตายได้นะ
แล้วงูเห่าอ่ะอ่ามันก็ชอบออกมาตอนกลางคืน
ใช่มั้ยคะอ่าอยู่ตามทุ่งนาที่มีฟาร์มข้าว
หรือในป่าในภูเขาแล้วก็บางตัวเนี่ยครู
ปุ๊กยาว 100  -180 ซมเลยนะ
โอว่าถ้าบางที่เมีอาหารเยอะเนี่ยมันอาจจะ
ตัวใหญ่กว่านี้ก็ได้นะอนะแล้วครูปุ๊กลอง
คิดดูเมื่อกี้ครูปุ๊กเห็นเนี่ยมันออกสีดำ
ๆใช่มยใช่เรามองไม่ค่อยเข้าใจเนาะบางที
มันมืดใช่มั้ยเวลาเราตื่นเช้าๆหรือว่าตอน
เย็นเราเดินที่รีสอร์ทในป่าที่เราไปกาง
เต็นท์อย่างเงี้ยค่ะอืนะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ย
ถ้าครูบีจะเดินตอนกลางคืนเนี่ยครูบีต้อง
มีไม้ยาวๆไว้ก่อนค่ะแล้วแล้วก็ทำให้มันมี
เสียงเพราะโดยปกติเนาะงูมันไม่ได้อยากกัด
คนอนะถ้ามันเจอได้ยินเสียงดังน่ะมันก็จะ
หนีใช่นะยกเว้นเราไปเหยียบโดนมันหรือไป
โดนมันเข้าเนี่ยมันก็จะตกใจอืนะแล้วก็อาจ
จะชูคอขึ้นมาแผ่แม่เบี้ยแล้วก็ฉกเลยค่ะ
ฉกนะพอฉกก็กัดแล้วก็ปล่อยพิษใช่มั้ยใช่พิ
พิษออกมาอันนี้ก็อันตรายค่ะนะเพราะว่าตัว
มันก็สีดำๆนะอืก็คือว่าถ้าเกิดว่าเราโดน
งูเห่ากัดเราต้องรีบไปโรงพยาบาลใช่มั้ยอ
ใช่นเพราะว่ามันทิษทิษมันจะวิ่งเข้ามาที่
หัวใจเราก็จะเริ่มหายใจไม่ออกนะคะอ่าใช่
ค่ะก็ต้องนะหาอะไรมารัดไว้ก่อนที่มันจะ
ถึงหัวใจเรานะใช่อาจจะถหัวใจอืแล้วก็รัด
ค่ะงูงูงูกัดที่มืออ่าอ่าก็รัดเนี่ยแขน
อืมรัดที่แขนนะคะออเพราะว่ามือเนี้ยพิษงู
เี่มันจะวิ่งเข้ามาที่หัวใจใช่มั้ยครู
ปุ๊กใช่ค่ะนะออต้องรัดแขนอใช่รักให้นนนะ
แล้วก็เอ่อรัดอย่างเดียวไม่พอนะบางทีต้อง
ปล่อยบ้างนิดหน่อยแล้วก็ปิดแล้วก็รัดใหม่
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยนะเพราะว่ามันอาจจะทำให้
ไม่มีเลือดไปเลี้ยงที่มือนะอืนะก็คือรีบ
รีบช่วยเหลือตัวเองแล้วก็รีบไปโรงพยาบาล
ให้เร็วที่สุดถ้าเราไม่เข้าใจวิธีเอ่อใน
การที่จะเอาพิษออกใช่มั้ยูบีเคยดูหนัง
หนังฮอลลีวูดน่ะมือกัดที่มือโอ้โหแล้วก็
มีผู้ชายหล่อเนี่ย
โอ้โหอันนี้เนี่ยไม่ควรทำอย่างยิ่ง
ค่ะอร่อยผู้ชายตายได้นะคะอ้าเหรอคะแมน
อยากช่วยผู้หญิงอ้าถ้าคนที่มีแผลข้างใน
ปากเนี่ยอืพี่ปูก็เข้าได้เหมือนกันนะ
อันตรายเหรอคะถ้าช่วย่อใช่เหมือนนักเรียน
มีแผลข้างในปากนะอาจจะแบบเคี้ยวเกี้ยว
อาหารแล้วกัดปากตัวเอง
อมีแผลเนี่ยแล้วคุณไปดูดพิษงูออกเนี่ยโห
อันนี้ตายค่ะผู้หญิงไม่ตายผู้ชายตายใช่
ค่ะอ๋อมีมีผ้ามีเชือกแล้วก็มัดแบบนี้ดี
กว่าใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะก็คือพาไปโรงพยาบาลถูก
ต้องค่ะนะเห็นมเพราะว่างูเห่าเนี่ยมีพิษ
ทำให้ถึงตายได้นะคะแต่มันมีงูในประเทศไทย
ครูปุ๊กที่มีพิษมากกว่างูเห่าอีกนะอ่า
เพราะว่างูตัวต่อไปเนี่ยนะส่วนมากแล้ว
เนี่ยเราจะพบเห็นเนี่ยในภาคใต้จะเยอะมาก
กว่าแล้วก็ตัวใหญ่กว่าด้วยค่ะรูบีนะตัว
ใหญ่กว่าเหรอใช่นะงูจงอางครุณู้เคยเห็นใน
คลิปในข่าวอ่ะนะฮะในข่าวประเทศไทยเนาะว่า
จับงูจงอางเนี่ยตัวใหญ่โอโหยาว 5 เมตเลย
อ่ะรูบีอืหือเดี๋ยวนะยาว 5 เมตใช่ค่ะ
อุ้ยทำไมน่ากลัวอคือภาคกลางเนี่ยเรามีงู
จงอางเหมือนกันแต่มันจะไม่ได้ตัวใหญ่เท่า
กับทางภาคใต้นะทางภาคใต้จะใหญ่กว่าอืใหญ่
จริงค่ะอ่ะให้นักเรียนดูก่อนแล้วกันนะ
เมื่อกี้เนี่ยเป็นงูเห่าต่อไปเนี่ยงู
จงอางนี่นี่ตัวนี้ก็ไม่ต่ำกว่า 4 เมตรนะ
กูปุ๊กว่า
โอ้โหอัน
นี้วิ่งคงไม่ทันล่ะค่ะครูปุ๊กจะวิ่งหนี
ยังไงนะคะดู
สิเป็นงูที่หน้าตาโกรธเนาะเอ้อใช่จับฉัน
ทำไมเออนะอันนี้งูจงอางคือยาวด้วย 4 ม 5
มตโหใช่ค่ะแล้วแล้วมีพิษด้วยใช่แล้ว
ประเด็นสำคัญก็คืองูจงอางเนี่ยมันจะชูคอ
ขึ้นมาเมันตัวมันจะชูได้สูงมากนะบางที
เนี่ยอยู่ในระยะอกเราพอดีเลยอ่ะใกล้กับ
หัวใจ
อืถ้ามันฉกแล้วหรือกัดหรือว่านะพิษเนี่ย
พ่นพิษออกมาเนี่ยนะมันก็จะอยู่บริเวณใกล้
ๆใช่มั้ยถ้าโดนตาก็ตาบอดได้มองไม่เห็นนะ
อืมอืเพราะว่ามันสามารถคือมันยาว 3 มต 4
เอาแค่ 2 เมตเนี่ยมันก็สามารถชูคอขึ้นมา
ได้สูงแล้วเนาะยกขึ้นมาใช่คือมันจะสูง
กว่างูเห่างูเห่าเนี่ยนักเรียนง่ายๆมันจะ
ชูขึ้นมาเนี่ยประมาณหัวเข่านะแค่หัวเข่า
เราก็คือแค่ขาอือนะแต่อันเนี้ยถ้าเป็นงู
จงอางเนี่ยขึ้นมาถึงหน้าอกเราเลยอืนะ
โอ้โหถ้าครูบีล่ะคะสูง 150  10 ซมจ๊ะเอ๋
กันน่าจะแบบอยู่ให้หน้าเลย
นะโอมันสูงมากใช่มยก็คือสามารถแบบอย่าง
งี้ได้เลยใช่มั้ยคะนะโดยเฉพาะงูมันจะดุ
ตอนที่มันมีไข่ค่ะอืเขาบอกงูจงอางเป็นงู
ที่หวงไข่มากๆใครอย่าไปใกล้รังที่มันอยู่
เบ้านของมันเนี่ยนะของแล้วมันมีไข่อยู่
เนี่ยใครไปขโมยเนี่ยตายแน่ๆค่ะ
อืน่ากลัวใช่มากนะคะแล้วก็เป็นงูที่มีพิษ
มากๆแล้วก็ยาว 3 มต 4 เมตนะคะใช่ค่ะเพราะ
ว่าด้วยความที่งูมันตัวใหญ่พิษมันก็เลย
เยอะปริมาณพิษเนี่ยเยอะ
นะก็อันตรายตรงนั้นล่ะค่ะปุุกค่ะถ้าเกิด
ไปเดินในป่าแล้วเจองูจงอางแล้วมันฉกเข้า
ไปเนี่ยมันกัดเข้าไปเนี่ยเปอร์เซ็นต์ที่
จะรอดตายเนี่ยกี่เปอร์เซ็นต์คะเนี่ยโอ
น้อยค่ะเพรากว่าจะไปถึงโรงพยาบาลใช่มยใช่
เพราะว่าที่มันกัดเนี่ยระดับความสูงเนี่ย
มันใกล้หัวใจนะก็ต้องระวังเนาะถ้ามันโฉก
มาแล้วโดนหน้าผากครูบีเเนี่ยนะครูบีก็
ต้องรัดคอใช่มยกันพิษเข้าหัวใจไม่รู้จะ
ช่วยตัวเองยังไงหรือคนจะช่เรายังไงเนาะ
เออนั่นแหละอือครูบีคิดว่าแล้วงูจงอาง
เนี่ยถ้ามันจะฉกเนี่ยมันก็ต้องคิดเอาให้
เราตายนะอาจจะโดนหน้าโดนคอโดนใกล้ๆหัวใจ
อ่ะนะอืคือโดยปกติเ้าจะไม่มาไม่มาทำร้าย
เราแต่ถ้าเค้ารู้สึกเค้าตกใจเค้ากลัวกลัว
ว่าเราจะไปทำอันตรายเค้าเราจะไปเอาไข่ของ
เค้าเนี่ยเคก็จะต้องป้องกันตัวเองเค้าจะ
ขึ้นมาเลยนะแผ่แม่เบี้ยเหมือนกันนะแต่
ข้างข้างหลังแม่เบี้ยเค้าจะไม่มีเอ่อเป็น
อะไรนะดอกจันหรือว่าโลโก้การบินไทยของครู
บีอ๋อข้างหลังเนี่ยจะไม่มีโลโกนะคะใช่มัน
นะแต่ดูน่ากลัวเนาะใช่นะเพราะว่าถ้าถ้า
เราเราดูดูหน้างูจงอางเนาะอือฮึเห็นมดูสิ
อหน้าตาแบบเอาเรื่องค่ะหน้ากลัวเป็น
มาเฟียเลยนะคะหน้าตาเนี่ยอือ่ะไหนมีูตัว
ต่อไปมั้ยคะมีค่ะนะในประเทศไทยเนี่ยงูมี
พิษนอกจากจะเป็นงูเห่าที่มีโลโก้ข้างหลัง
ใช่มยงูจงอางโอโหยาว 4 ม 5 มตอืใช่ยังมี
อีกค่ะครูปุ๊กงูอะไรคะรูบีเอออันนี้งู
อะไรูสามเหลี่ยมหรือเปล่า
เอ้าครูปุ๊กก็ต้องดูนะว่ามันสามเหลี่ยม
มั้ย
เออเดี๋ยวลองลองดูค่ะว่ามันสามเหลี่ยม
หรือเปล่านะเพราะว่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยเห็นแว๊บ
ๆจากของครูบีเเนี่ยรูปภาพที่ครูบีมีเนี่ย
น่าจะใช่ค่ะใช่มั้ยอือให้ดูแบบใกล้ๆก่อน
นะคะอ่าเรามีรูปให้ดูอีกเยอะนะคะเห็นมย
ตรงข้างหลังมันเนี่ยมันจะสูงที่สุดนะออ
เห็นมยเนี่ยตรงแล้วมันเป็นทรงเหมือนสาม
เหลี่ยมค่ะ
พีระมิดนะสามเหลี่ยมอย่างเงี้ยเขาก็เลย
เรียกว่างูสามเหลี่ยมอุ๊ยง่ายนะภาษา
ไทยจริงมั้ยคะภาษาไทยง่ายจริงมั้ยครูปุ๊ก
ง่ายนิดเดียวค่ะง่ายนิดเดียวค่ะนะก็สระงู
สามเหลี่ยมเนี่ยก็เป็นงูพิษชนิดนึงใน
ประเทศไทยมีเพียงแต่พบเห็นได้น้อยมากกว่า
งูเห่ากับงูจงอางเนาะนะมันก็จะออกหากิน
ตอนกลางคืนนี่แหละนะคะแล้วก็ชอบอาศัยอยู่
ในที่ที่เหมือนทุ่งนาในป่าป่าที่มันมีน้ำ
ด้วยนะน้ำนิดหน่อยอ่ะค่ะนะ
เขามันชอบแบบเหมือนมีน้ำนิดๆให้มันชื้น
แฉะอย่างเงี้ยค่ะนะอาจจะเป็นบ่อน้ำแล้วมี
ต้นไม้ตามปากตามภูเขาเวลาเราเดินก็ต้อง
ระวังเนาะอ่าก็มีพิษนะคะใช่นะอันนี้จะตัว
จะไม่ได้ใหญ่มากนะก็ประมาณซัก 2 เมตอืนะ
อันนี้คือแต่ตัวเมียตัวเมียก็จะมีขนาดที่
ใหญ่กว่าตัวผู้ค่ะอืออมีตัวผู้ตัวเมียที่
มีมีความแตกต่างในเรื่องขนาดใช่มตัวใหญๆอ
ใช่ค่ะอืนะอันนี้ก็คือถ้าคุณโดนกัดมันก็
จะมีพิษเข้าสู่ร่างกายก็อาจทำให้เสีย
ชีวิตหรือว่าตายได้เนาะอันนี้เป็นงูสาม
เหลี่ยม
อ่านะสีมันก็จะออกแบบที่เราให้ดูเนาะค่ะ
อ่าอ่ะงต่อไปค่ะครูบีเดี๋ยวเราเวลาไม่ทัน
ออมีงูหลายชนิดที่ต้องเอามาให้นักเรียนดู
เนาะว่าระวังนะคะเวลามาเที่ยวตามภูเขาใน
ประเทศไทยนะคะนี่ค่ะอันนี้ก็เป็นสีดำสี
ขาวเลยค่ะครูปุ๊ก
อ่าอันนี้เนี่ยเป็นงูลักษณะมีสามเหลี่ยม
เหมือนกันนะครูบีใช่แต่ว่าสีใช่สีไม่
เหมือนกันเห็นมยถูกต้องูอันนี้เนี่ยชื่อ
งูชื่อว่าทับสมิงคาอุ๊ยชื่อยากนะแต่เพราะ
ดีงูทับ
สมิงคาื่อเพราะนะแล้วก็ชื่อยาวด้วยงูทับ
สมิงคาใช่งูทับสมิงคลา
นะก็เหมือนๆกับงูสามเหลี่ยมเลยค่ะลักษณะ
เนี่ยคือออกหากินตอนกลางคืนอาศัยอยู่ตาม
พื้นที่ที่มีแหล่งน้ำที่มีความชื้นชื้นก็
คือมีน้ำเนาะนะอ่ะแล้วก็ลำตัวเนี่ยจะกลม
มากกว่างูสามเหลี่ยม
อ่ะถ้าดูใช่มั้ยเนี่ยงูสามเหลี่ยมเห็น
มั้ยคะอันนี้งูทับ
สมิงคาคล้ายๆกันเนาะครูปุ๊กใช่ค่ะคล้ายๆ
เพียงแต่ 4 ไม่เหมือนเนาะูบีใช่แต่มัน
เป็นงูที่มีพิษก็คือถ้ามันกัดเราเราก็ตาย
ได้เหมือนกันเนาะเพราะว่ามีพิษเป็นงูมี
พิษนะคะค่ะนะก็เป็นงูมีพิษเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยนักเรียนก็จำรูปภาพไว้ถ้าเจอแบบนี้
งูแบบนี้ก็มีให้ห่างๆค่ะอืนะอย่าไปใกล้นะ
คะเพราะมันมีพิษนะคะใช่นะครูปุ๊กคะเราไป
ดูงูต่อไปเลยดีกว่าได้เลยค่ะเป็นงูอะไรคะ
รูบีโอ้งูชนิดนี้เนี่ยครูบีไม่เคยเห็นนะ
เขาบอกว่าเป็นแมวเซราค่ะครูปุ๊กอ่างูแมว
เซาเคยได้ยินชื่อค่ะไม่เคยเห็นตัวจริง
เหมือนกันนะเห็นมหูมันมีลายแบบ
สีน้ำตาลสีดำเหมือนมันชอบนอนหรือเปล่าคะ
ทำไมคือเวลาเวลาเค้าเหมือนไอ้เนี่ยเจะมี
เสียงเหมือนแมวมีความสุขอ่ะเวลาแมวแบบขืด
ืดืดเสียงมันจะแบบลักษณะแบบนั้นน่ะอืมัน
ก็เลยแบบคนก็เรียกว่างูแมวเซา
นะมีเสียงออกมาเวลามันนอนใช่มมันก็จะชอบ
ขดตัวนะคะก็นอนอยู่แบบนั้นแล้วก็มากๆ
เนี่ยไม่ค่อยชอบอยู่บนต้นไม้นะก็อยู่ตาม
พื้นน่ะค่ะนะแล้วก็จู่โจมเนี่ยมันก็ส่วน
มากมันจะขดตัวแล้วก็มันขึ้นไปฉกเลยอ่ะอื
มันจะอออย่างงนี้ถ้ามันอยู่บนพื้นดินแล้ว
เราเดินป่าเดินภูเขาถ้าไปเหยียบเนี่ยมัน
ก็ฉกเลยใช่มั้ยใช่แล้วมันโจมตีเร็วด้วย
ค่ะนะมันจะขดแล้วตัวมันน่ะกับใบไม้แห้งๆ
อ่ะครูบีมันจะคล้ายกันมากเนาะอืลำตัวก็จะ
ยาวประมาณ 90  -150 ซมนะคะเกล็ดมันก็จะ
เป็นสีน้ำตาลเข้มแบบเนี้ยค่ะแล้วก็มีขอบ
สีดำอืโอู้สามเหลี่ยดีว่างูชนิดนี้น่า
กลัวมากนะครูปุ๊กเพราะว่าบางทีถ้ามันชอบ
นอนขดแล้วมีใบไม้ปิดเนี่ยโอ้โหแล้วฉกเร็ว
ด้วยใช่มยใช่นะเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยก็ต้อง
ระวังค่ะนะอนะอันนี้เป็นงูมีพิษเหมือนกัน
เนาะอ่ะงูต่อไปค่ะงต่อไปต่อไปงูกะปะค่ะงู
กะปะอืมนะงูกับอ่ามากๆเนี่ยจะอยู่ตามสวน
ยางพาราค่ะนะในป่าชื้นๆเหมือนกันลักษณะ
เหมือนกันแล้วก็ชอบอออกหากินตอนกลางคืน
เพราะว่ากลางคืนเนี่ยไม่ร้อนอืนะลำตัวก็
จะยาวประมาณ 50-80 ซมค่ะตัวเมียก็เหมือน
กันค่ะมีขนาดใหญ่กว่าตัวผู้อืนะคะลักษณะ
ยาวใช่นะจะกระปะออ่างูกะปะนะคล้ายๆงูแมว
เซรามยก็ไม่ถึงกับคล้ายทีเดียวเนาแต่สี
เป็นใกล้เคียงกันนะสเอมันจะมีลายที่ต่าง
กันอยู่นะเนี่ยถ้าเราสังเกตดีๆนะคะมันจะ
อยู่ตรงนี้นะถูกต้องอืมคอันนี้คืองูมีพิษ
เหมือนกันนะคะงูงูอะไรนะครูปุ๊กงูกะปะอื
งูกะปะอ่ะเดี๋ยวจะหมดเวลาก่อนงูมีตัวสุด
ท้ายเนี่ยน่ากลัวสุดเลยเพราะว่าบางทีเรา
ดูไม่เข้า
ใจใช่ค่ะเพราะว่ามันมีสีเขียวเนาะแต่ว่า
งูเขียวเรามีเยอะบางตัวไม่มีพิษบางตัวมี
พิษเนาะในเนี้ยที่มันมีพิษเนี่ยนักเรียน
ต้องสังเกตที่ปลายหางค่ะนะอเพราะว่างู
เนี้ยมันชื่องูขีดเวหางไม่้นะนะหางมัน
เป็นสีแดงมันจะออกสีแดงๆมันจะไม่เหมือน
กับงูเขียวที่ไม่มีพิษงูเขียวไม่มีพิษมัน
จะห่างตัวทั้งตัวทั้งหางปลายหางก็จะเป็น
สีเดียวกันคือสีเขียวแต่อันเนี้ยงูเขียว
หางไม้เนี่ยก็แสดงว่ามันจะเป็นงูพิษชนิด
นึงค่ะนะแต่ถ้าดูแบบนี้ไม่รู้ไงเพราะเรา
มองไม่เห็นหาถูกมั้ยคะใช่ค่ะเพราะฉะนั้น
แต่ถ้าเราอยากรู้ว่ามันมีพิษมั้ยให้เราดู
หางใช่มั้ยครูปุ๊กใช่ค่ะปลายหางมันเนี่ย
เห็นมั้ยเมันจะเป็นสีแดงๆค่ะสีน้ำตาลแดงๆ
นะอันเนี้ยมีพิษค่ะโออย่างงี้ก็ถ้ามีต้น
ไม้ต้นไม้ก็สีเขียวงูก็สีเขียวอันนี้น่า
กลัวดูไม่เข้าใจว่าเป็นงูหรือเป็นใบไม้
ใช่ค่ะูพูถึงบอกว่าเราต้องมีไม้สักอันนึง
ยาวๆที่เดินแล้วก็ตีๆให้มันมีเสียงดัง
เพราะว่าพอสัตว์มันแบบตกใจมันก็จะแบบหนี
ไปเนาะนะอ่ะโอ้โหพูดไปแล้วมีงูมีพิษหลายๆ
ชนิดเลยนะคะก็แต่ว่าเราหมดเวลาแล้วไงครู
ปุ๊กวันนี้ขอลาทุกคนไปก่อนนะเพราะว่าหมด
เวลาแล้วนะคะเอาไว้เจอคต่อไปนะคะสวัสดี
ค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ